of the problem with nurmagomedov
obviously was the last fight before this
previous spectacular fight with Barbosa
he didn't make the way because he had to
go to the hospital so that's a different
animal that's like you pushed it so far
that they were they wanted to make sure
you stayed alive so they had to bring it
to a hospital so they obviously realized
there's some changes that need to be
made they made those changes and [ __ ]
hell on Friday and on Saturday night
rather [ __ ] how unbelievable that was
it's really weird sometimes when you in
any sport I don't care what it is when
you see somebody you know Jordan in his
prime you just you just can't cover the
guy it's almost like he's the only one
on the court yeah never game enough it
was like he was the only one in the cage
it was everything was inevitable
everything was inevitable
yeah leadings were inevitable you know
even if you hit them congratulations
now you're on your ass getting punched
in the face over and over again you
can't get up you're getting mauled like
immediately and it against an excellent
fighter I just can't forget barbels is
amazing amazing and he made him look
like he's the look on his face when he
got up when Barbosa was like hey you
were better than me you know it was
almost like a yeah like I sure I
wouldn't even mad it was just when you
see somebody that much better it's it's
back to the drawing board well I was
super impressed with barbozza being able
to make it to the final bell I mean that
was amazing just being able to do that
that shows you what a dominant
performance it was by a guy like Habib
but you also realized like what what a
world-class fighter Barbosa is that he
did keeps throwing wheel kicks in the
third round and even landed one of them
it just didn't have much on an analogy
anymore but [ __ ] man he was still trying
to win after a horrendous mauling for
eight plus minutes you know what I
really look at fighters when I really
when I really focus on them especially
the face in between rounds I look for
that breaking moment of yeah you know
Vitor Belfort Randy Couture knees
sitting on the ground just like beat
this guy's beat it's it's when you look
at them in-between around and you see
that like what am i doing in here that's
when you know you know the men from the
boys mentally speaking and you know in
in belt or potential pit ball
we fought when he fought Daniel Straus
he's getting beat up for like four
rounds and every round he looked like
Lemmy Adam there wasn't there wasn't
anyone in the you know toward the end of
the fourth round with the rear naked
choke he just never quits and I always
look for that breaking moment and that's
when that's when you real that's what
really separates the guys who are
mentally 100 cent there and those were
those were I think Barbosa got beaten
but I don't think he got broken no I
don't think if you think about the
amount of time during that fight he was
actually getting his ass kicked when I
said eight families at rounds I met
minutes I think there was like eight
minutes of prolonged
top time and beating in that fight yeah
Plus and then there's all the backward
movement trying to get away throwing
those inside leg kicks and doing
everything he can everything he can to
create space but for eight [ __ ]
minutes he never gave up was just or
whatever it was 15 minutes just getting
the [ __ ] beaten out of him he kept
trying to win he wasn't capable of doing
it but he never broke uh Teddy Atlas
said fighters make an agreement
I'll stop trying to win if you'll stop
trying to hurt me Wow yeah and he never
did that I never went look just go away
just like leave me alone and I'll back
up and you can beat me he never did that
he kept throwing the whole time which is
incredible but just no answer how many
ten eighths were there on the scorecards
like well the thing is what a 10-8 every
round
it was least old it was the old scoring
to the Nevada has an invited the new
rules so in that for people don't know
the new rules make it easier to make
distinctions between a 10-9 around ten
eight round ten seven round which I
haven't done to them no that's not so
that's an old-school ten eight yeah
there's some ridiculous scorecards that
seem to indicate some of us that even
though the new rules are better and the
states haven't adopted them the judges
have decided to adopt them and some sort
of a weird non declared way because it
just definitely seemed there was a much
larger disparity in the numbers in the
scorecards yeah but
nurmagomedov just just mauled him mauled
him I mean mauled him in a way that you
go oh god you're not even there he's
just on such another level that you the
odds of you beating him drop so
substantially after the first minute and
a half after you get you saw the look on
barbosa's face there's like two minutes
plus into the first round and he's
trying to get up you see the look in his
face
[ __ ] how am I gonna deal with this yeah
like this is so next level